et invités de ce 19 ans la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur valérie
pécresse bonsoir sans les syndicats se
sont dits on l'a vu globalement rassurés
par ce nouveau texte ça veut dire que ce
soir la situation est débloquée
je crois qu'on a on est parvenus à un
texte d'équilibré et un texte qui
suscite maintenant une large adhésion
dans la communauté universitaire alors
c'est est vital parce que cette réforme
elle est urgente ça fait 20 ans qu'on
n'a pas fait la réforme des universités
ça fait 20 ans que tous mes
prédécesseurs qui se sont lancés dans
l'aventuré se sont heurtés à toutes les
forces qui dans le pays sont hostiles au
changement et je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
société française était en train de se
débloquer sur ce sujet et pour moi c'est
très important mais pour cela vous avez
accepté des concessions importantes sur
les trois points qui posaient problème
justement je crois que les objectifs du
texte et j'allais dire tout son contenu
sont là c'est quoi l'objectif du texte
c'est de tout simplifier on a des
conseils d'administration qui sont à 60
mans on les passe entre 20 et 30
on a des présidents qui sont élus par
140 personnes quelques fois ça fait 23
tours de scrutin dans les universités où
on les passe à une quinzaine de
personnes on a un an un an et demi pour
recruter un enseignant dans l'université
française
on passe à trois quatre mois vous voyez
tout ça on débloque
c'est un outil pour faire la grande
réforme de l'université qui va ensuite
suivre avec les questions de la
condition de vie étudiant de la réussite
au diplôme
parce que ça c'est ce qui intéresse et
étudiants et puis la question de
l'insertion professionnelle que nous
avons intégrés dans le texte comme une
mission l'université alors justement
pour débloquer la situation pour apaiser
les esprits il a fallu l'intervention du
président nicolas sarkozy
en fait vous attendiez son feu vert pour
assouplir le texte je crois que le
président de la république aujourd'hui
c'est lui qui a la légitimité devant le
peuple français de porter les réformes à
cause de ce lien très particulier qui
l'a créé pendant la campagne et il est
celui qui est le mieux à même de
convaincre les français qu'il faut
bouger il a reçu tous les membres de la
communauté universitaire il leur a
affirmé son engagement politique et
budgétaire sans précédent pôle
université parce qu'il considère que
l'université et la recherche c'est des
deux priorités essentielles de la france
de demain
je crois que ça ça les a beaucoup
rassuré et ça nous a permis ensuite
d'avancé parce qu'une concertation bas
c'est évidemment à pezi des peurs et
puisse essayer de faire converger les
points de vue et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on a fait converger les prix s'interroge
parfois sur la marge de manoeuvre qui
reste au ministre vous vous ne vous êtes
pas senti désavoué ou floués dans la
direction de ce dossier moi je me suis
sentie senti pardon pleinement soutenu
par le président dans toutes les
propositions que je lui ai fait la
première c'était de dire que toutes les
universités auront le droit à
l'autonomie d'ici cinq ans il y aura pas
une université à deux vitesses et en pas
d'université qui seront laissés pour
compte
la deuxième chose c'était dû proposer
que dans le cadre du chantier réussir la
licence
on parle aussi du master qu'on n'en
parle pas dans cette loi pour pas
brouiller les messages et la troisième
chose c'était le conseil
d'administration avec un peu plus de
souplesse très rapidement concernant le
calendrier il sera maintenue comme prévu
présentation devant l'assemblée en
juillet application dès l'automne will
hayes le texte sera envoyé au conseil
d'état demain puisque c'est le conseil
d'état qui qui vérifie qu'il est
conforme à la constitution et puis
ensuite il arrivera au conseil des
ministres semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup
valérie pécresse d'avoir répondu à
l'invitation du 19 20